[Music]
[Music]
this work is incredible well that's my
favorite part about taking photos you
wander and find places like this which
makes me a little delirious i like what
your eyes are doing to me right now
that's really cheesy no it was um a
little cheesy um maybe i'll see you here
again sometime
you said he was cute
emojis are cute that guy is melting my
sunglasses tess
i think you could sell this stuff but
there is something that's missing from
like all of your photos you
[Music]
i love you tusa
[Music]
welcome back to the world of the living
maybe you don't like talking too much
about yourselves
i just wish i could see him one more
time even for a minute
he loved him and he knew that
[Music]
[Music]
i don't understand what is happening
when the separation is dramatic there's
unfinished business he's in the in
between
he's reaching out to you
reach back your ghost hunting assistant
has arrived a ouija board
oh my god
sorry that was me
if you do manage to cross there may be
no way back
home
[Music]
i'm still here
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you